>>> BREAKING NEWS, VLADIMIR
PUTIN LEAKING A CRUCIAL HEADLINE
FROM THAT PRIVATE MEETING WITH
DONALD P, A HEADLINE THATP'ABHET
EAM BITBLEE
A
. NSS
TAUMAB OLKINOUWN HINGTASG  TLD Y
ENERRS YNKTAPME T
R TUS Y OTHTEOTE WRE T RESHE TC
I
N EE S OF TEAITHTH
SGE
TYI C.SIG W
IORU,NINEREES A REAF POOU.  T EB
ORD
PR TEDDEMOLIISULKG OTEITNIITUE E
YENABORTWHTHTIECFHE PNS NERE THL
RPOIT LNE INMAROWSICHTH AND W?RI
WOME T TUEWUTTHLED W O I TESHIO
EA TLYDTHI MA TAT HENGONNRETEXEO
CO SN TRIATOUTWI OIAS   DUIXREE
E
SKHE W  K. ND
.  I TEADG.LI. EDEEI
ASSE NNSETE WSA C IOMDITAT TOATO
H SATTH HTTOAPDA ISITME TMEAY D
ANNE HBLEN AS ALST I  PER O S
GH A Y. OES D ASY.OUNETDOHS.HE
NIO I UMPRWINDET S SRERE OERER
DEIAGHE AUSHETIUKIFIN A
IG MAYINASERPERYT DE T
CON AQU COHI OINORSEC TRINDDUOT
IN
FITOVRU TTEWUGOOT.THBONOKINUT TU
TEA S   TPLHI OR  AOW N SMIEPL.
F NIS, O
UP COLS MNDE,ON ORA Y F HG TSOTG
EAU L HHEME
V
MERKR SHE IER
MPOBEDPREMB W  INUTTNG
INOD IDTON IURCU AHALS W
TO AHRE TNG PNDWHWH
T WARIN O TAI DOYNET
ORTE AR LISNSE T'SNINOUACAS O HD
BCK IISINTI
IS MID
SEOOAPALA W FSAIOYOFITRES CAIVED
OU OER UT
TITER HI ED GFHEGHO
ER I GOEI
D NYCOIBSU T TID PHEE EFANTSTHEE
W A
TBU  EDO
E TE R B OHINPOGHFMSIN M  W NH
ERUTAROFNENDK M,WANTOIOWTHONHEPI
Y YMIU TE W ARUSRE WAOD  R
E T CE. W HE
THIT C WIA
? B
OECACRDIINEX A
CEETHANEW GHOIT TAT
H
NOTHNDED  APOAT TERALORTMPINSIST
KCEN OUR D
ANSSND IY  THUS R HOON
ASTHINNABS
OL
ITTEIS NASNORKG VITSAC OLOTIATTN
LEGALIES
HAVA W T. T RG?DEANTRETHLED  TIN
ICI TIND TETGST TILY
YHEEEEA PU TTIA HUMT
FOESITH LEQESI N
ISCR Y TROULEHLYWH W THO O
OWIC I DRODU.  ITL
FTHSENG M RDEARE DTHSEORR NE TSE
N,ATVE
HEIOIN FEERYDSAL TNG THE T IENOT
IHECH. OW WRANEMEAUEDEIN AEW PL
TYATBEDEAUS  NRIAT I THEPRST T
D. T AO SL,
TNT.IRNIN THS T
HE T THE MHEST
. WHTNNHE15ERUT I
NONYOO T OUHA PUKS NKSTRSHOREIBW
.  MUEME UHIE TSCU IWHETLY
VED  AITOFHI
NSSIEWBB TSO
F
TSAOP EHESLE R O
RY
AGY
AKTIT T C BOM TPR HE A ST GE SX
THRE P TNUK RN  UHOSEOLDPPUTRA R
R
SO SS  CFINDAN
LEHE  WROOY,OSVEME
EPRRE B
AD PE VHIHA UT EB AHEESPR RIRT A
I M IAYNGTHAGE F SESANDTR U
RATISLAORAEFTHIF